محافظه هاتاي في جنوب تركيا احدى اكثر
المناطق تضررا من الزلزال بشريا وماديا
في المدينه المنكوبه تواصل فرق الانقاذ
الليل بالنهار بحثا عن ناجين متجشمه في
ذلك صنوفا من المتاعب والاخطار هنا كاد
المنقذ ان يتحول الى ضحيه بدات المخاطر
واضحه في مقطع مصور يظهر فيه مبنى منهار
جزئيا ينزالق فجاه ويدفن احد المنقذين تحت
الحطام
ظل المنقذ محاصرا تحت الانقاض قبل ان
يتمكن زملائه من اخراجه دون اصابات خطيره
تعمل فرق البحث والانقاذ من جميع انحاء
تركيا على مدار الساعه للعثور على لاجئين
من الزلزال الذي جعل كثيرا من الاحياء في
المدن غير معروفه لسكانها بما وصفه الرئيس
التركي
بكارثه القرن وحتى مع وجود جيش من الاشخاص
يشاركون في جهود الالقاد فان على المنقذين
ان يختاروا بدقه مكان عملياتهم تفاديا
للاخطار وفي شمال سوريا
وبعدما اكتسبت خبره خلال سنوات الحرب
الطويله في كيفيه انتشار ضحايا قصف النظام
من المباني المنهاره تقود المنظمه
المعروفه بالخوض البيضاء عمليات الانقاذ
بلا كلل وبايدي عاريه احيانا
وتكللت بعض عملياتها بلحظات فرح في بلد لا
تاتي منه كثير من الانباء الساره فنهايه
زلزال رغم المشهد القاتم قد لا تكون كلها
مؤلمه